heed it by the rumors read into it too
much feeding it for some true love ask
him what do you love hard to find what
the truth is but the truth was that the
truth suck always seem to do stuff but
this time it was too much kanye west's
new album donda dropped over the weekend
now we're breaking down all the lyrics
that seem to be inspired by his split
from his estranged wife kim kardashian
something from my heart first up
hurricane
architecture digest but i needed home
improvement
that line seemingly refers to the
california home kim and kanye purchased
in 2014. the former couple renovated the
house and it was featured in
architectural digest in 2020. then
there's this line from the same track
here i go on a new trip here i go i get
too lit here i go i get too rich here i
go with a new chick many fans suggest
this line could be a reference to kanye
being romantically linked to arena shake
in june following his split from the 40
year old kkw beauty founder reports
surfaced earlier this month that the
rapper and supermodel had called things
off but a source previously told et that
they were never actually an official
couple and were just spending time
together without any strings attached
next up kanye's song off the grid which
features lyrics that seem to reference
his ranch in wyoming mass on my face you
can't see what i'm gonna do had to move
away from
the 44 year old musician began spending
the majority of his time in wyoming as
far back as 2018. he was also living
there in 2020 when he shared a string of
since-deleted tweets calling out kim's
family and slamming her mom kris jenner
claiming she stirs up drama i pray that
my family will never resent me and she
fell in love with me
a source recently told e.t
kanye wants to get back with kim and he
has been trying to win her over again
and re-prove himself as for his track
new again it appears to be about kanye
talking to a new romantic partner
implying no one will ever live up to kim
in his eyes
though then there's this line from the
song lord i need you which seemingly
refers to his relationship with the
skim's founder
when you said give me a ring you really
meant a ring huh
turned out to be more than just a fling
huh three hours to get back from palm
springs huh who you know spent an hour
in walgreens huh you know you always be
my favorite prom queen in that same song
kanye seems to call out kim's wealthy
family and
upbringing so you had a business 16 i
could barely afford the audi we learned
on keeping up with the kardashians that
kim's dad gifted her with a white bmw
for her 16th birthday
kim attended all three of kanye's donda
listening events and a line from that
same track seems to reference his ex
showing her support for his music
but you came here to show that you're
still in love with me and in his song
jail kanye candidly talks about a
breakup
[Music]
he also says this
[Music]
according to reports kanye changed his
number in march after kim filed for
divorce and would only communicate
through his reps i always believe and
trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart kim filed for
divorce from the grammy-winning rapper
back in february after nearly seven
years of marriage the two share four
children together and have remained on
good terms since their split in fact at
kanye's recent listening event in
chicago kim came out dressed in a
balenciaga wedding gown he's done
miracles on me
he's done miracles on me now a source
tells et that while they haven't
actually reconciled kim is considering
her options with kanye but keeping her
kids top of mind
you